your spine is composed of individual
Bones called vertebrae your vertebrae
form a protective tunnel called the
spinal canal which surrounds the spinal
cord as it travels down the length of
your spine on each side of the spinal
cord spinal nerves exit the spinal canal
through small bony channels called
neural foramina
cervical spinal nerves travel through
your neck shoulders and arms between
your skull and your ribcage our seven
vertebrae that make up your cervical
spine
flexible pads known as intervertebral
disks provide a cushion between your
vertebrae for the range of movements
your head and neck make every day the
cervical spine supports the weight of
your head allows your head to rotate and
tilt and helps you bend your neck
cervical disc pressure increases when
your neck bends forward backward and
sideways
intervertebral discs consist of a tough
outer ring of tissue called the annulus
fibrosus and a soft jelly like center
called the nucleus pulposus
during a traumatic injury your spine may
be forced forward or hyper flexed
causing your vertebrae to compress the
front of one or more of your cervical
discs beyond normal limits hyper flexion
of the neck is a common cause of
cervical injury that occurs in motor
vehicle accidents and some sports as a
result your jelly-like nucleus pulposus
is pushed backward into your annulus
fibrosus thinning your annulus and
causing small tears after a cervical
disc injury your annulus fibrosus begins
to weaken and tear and your nucleus
pulposus becomes dry and stiff over time
these changes make your discs
susceptible to further injury as your
intervertebral disc deteriorates a weak
annulus fibrosus can allow your nucleus
pulposus to bulge changing the discs
normal shape and flexibility
depending on its size and location the
bulge may push on or impinge one of your
spinal nerves
or your spinal cord causing pain and
inflammation
central disc bulges project backward
into your spinal canal
lateral disc bulges push into your
neural foramen severe cervical disc
injuries can tear open your annulus
fibrosus pressure from your vertebrae
may force the nucleus pulposus out of
the torn annulus causing a disc
herniation a herniated disc can impinge
your spinal nerves or spinal cord
interrupt normal nerve signals and cause
symptoms such as pain numbness or
weakness in one or both of your arms
treatment for cervical disc injuries may
include rest anti-inflammatory
medication muscle relaxants ice or heat
applied to the injured area physical
therapy steroid injections and in more
severe cases surgery